[Music]
please don't get involved
yeah i'm good to go chen it is monday
morning may 30th
on this lovely memorial day um shout out
to
all the people uh that are you know in
the military
um that
served their time in the military it is
a uh
a big deal man and this is us um just
kind of honoring all those u.s military
personnel who have died while serving
the united states armed forces man and
uh you're talking about uh i come from a
military family
i'm the only one that didn't have the
balls to join the military uh
my mom's uh dad my grandpa was in the
army my dad's dad my other grandpa was
in the marines my uncle was in the
marines my dad was in the navy my other
uncle was in the air force um the list
goes on the entire military family so
i'm the only one
that didn't join the military it's one
of the biggest regrets i have but here
we are um
so yeah there's nothing uh
you know i'm not the biggest holiday guy
but memorial day for my family and for a
lot of you out there in america is a big
deal so um
nothing but gratitude and i can't thank
those currently serving enough man you
guys are literally the the lifeline of
this country and uh you're selfless and
you guys are just straight up badasses
and uh
you know military police force all that
[ __ ] you guys are just complete
absolute badasses and we need you now
more than ever
so uh
my hat's off to you man i would love to
do a a military torching that'd be dope
wouldn't it be fun hell yeah that'd be
so dope uh the demo looked exactly the
same as mine now a lot of dudes dudes a
lot of dudes who are in shape so
um speaking of uh military um weird
transition whatever uh last night i did
a little date night with a wifey winsol
top gun
now have you seen chin i just saw it
yeah this weekend
dude
i so the reviews you know i'm not the
biggest review guy what other people say
i usually don't care but the reviews on
this it was like my god everyone's
hanging off tom cruise's nuts
and uh my buddy is the one who
represents uh the director and he told
me
three years ago he's i'm telling you man
this new top gun blah blah blah
now miles teller and i have a history
when i first uh
came to la my crew was scotty mcknight
and miles teller and the time miles
teller wasn't doing [ __ ] he's doing
auditions trying to do his thing this is
i don't know 10 12 years ago trying to
figure this thing out and i remember he
always had like this
i don't want to say arrogance it's not
arrogance he had this confidence in him
where he would say i'm gonna be the
biggest movie star in the world you know
at the time you know you guys booking
small geeks here like okay buddy okay
good luck my man
and show enough dude
this dude miles teller he is he what
happened in top gun is he's gonna he's
taking the baton from tom cruise and
going i'll take her from here tommy and
he is running he's the next time cruz
and he is just such a freaking good
person so talented such a badass he
probably came on the scene for most you
guys in that movie uh with he's playing
the drums yeah that won all the awards
he didn't win an award specifically but
um
my god man
he is just
such a talent man
yeah he's yeah the new top gun he's in
that and then he's also in the was it
the uh
is it the diversion fantastic four yeah
fantastic four but um
whiplash whiplash 21 and over was kind
of you know the one that footloose the
in 2011
um you know and then whiplash 21 and
over again a little famous but then
whiplash was really the big boy that was
really the big boy war dogs
uh war dogs was the one that me and
brian tell him find the kid where we
went to the opening of it and i didn't
know how hollywood works and we're with
you know miles
who's a my buddy and you know it's a big
movie and um todd phillips shoots it and
the whole staff is around and we got
done here what'd you think of it it's
all right
i didn't know that you're not supposed
to do that yeah and i have never been to
uh movie premier again after that nor
did i get invited anymore so i didn't
know it works like that but um
man
i'm top gun it's hard to live up to the
hype
this movie dude and my girl maxine is
[ __ ] you guys know this the gringo
poppy's hair dude my girl isn't aware of
top gun you didn't grow up in america
didn't know what the hell was doesn't
know the characters maverick goose
iceman doesn't know any of that and she
was like do you think i'm gonna like him
like just go
so we go she sneaks into her flaming hot
cheetos we go she's snack and i'm
striving nuts because i have that messy
foamy or whatever i can't listen to
people chew on food but powered through
it because tom cruise was so goddamn
good so does miles tell her she has no
background on top gun she cried several
times during the movie it got done she
looked at me she goes that's the best
movie i've i've ever seen i went i need
to calm down this is very good best
effort
you need to calm down but
as far as there's a reason why tom
cruise such a badass and i heard about
this years ago that they filmed this a
while ago but tom cruise like during the
pandemic was like no no this can't come
out on demand this ha people have to see
in the theaters they have to so he paid
all these fines lost all this money the
mark and he goes i don't care i'll pay
whatever i have to pay this has come out
in theaters when this pandemic's over my
i'm telling you guys i'm i didn't grow
up a big top gun fan dave days of
thunder's not a fan i was blood sport
big troubling little china
tengo in cash that was my [ __ ] bro
but this top gun
my god
god damn is it good
it's good man it was good
are you gonna hate on it no i'm not
gonna hate on it now now i will say this
when it kicks off
this is a spoiler but when it kicks off
and they're like they're in the the bar
you know the top gun bar and they won't
stop referring each other as their
fighter pilot names like they'll be like
oh what's up hang man what's up fanboy
and they just keep i'm like this is
cheesy is the whole movie going to be
this way and then it moves on and you
get why they call each other that yeah
i'm telling you man
i can't remember the last time i was in
the movie theater i'm trying to um
reverend did it when it got done i
stood up
stood up reverend i stood up dude
reverend the dark knight
titanic
avatar titanic was this [ __ ]
as a kid it was ace ventura billy
madison happy gilmore
i mean it's up there dude same feeling
same feeling i'm telling the entire
crowd after was done stood up and i
haven't seen i've never seen a movie
everyone kids women children
happened dude
i'm telling you the hype is real man and
i'm not a huge top gun guy it's
definitely good um
i'm not going to hate on it she and i
will fight you i don't know the real day
it was definitely good um i went with
someone that actually it follows the top
gun
the
the first movie so she was like crying
during the movie all these different
scenes it was very powerful yeah it was
about rooster who lost his dad
was it rooster was it yeah dude rooster
lost his dad yeah his dad was goose okay
there you go yeah we're going to go with
this no no so i thought actually it was
way better than i expected i didn't
expect to like it to like it at all yeah
so yeah i knew it was good when eric
griffin and the king the singing the
wing group chat you know eric sees every
movie he goes holy [ __ ] just got off top
gun unreal i was like yeah i've heard
that before and eric you know he's a big
movie goer then my brother who does not
use this
vocabulary very often goes holy [ __ ]
just got top gun
unbelievable i was like
i need to see it
the flying scenes the fights these days
they look so real
looking my nails the entire time like
this yeah it's so good yeah
i'm telling the time that the movie got
done i was like this
yeah dude it's nuts
do you know those jets to rent those
those jets are 11 000 an hour not not
including fuel and everything and they
have to use them for
all the days
it wasn't just like an hour of shooting
with the one jet it wasn't like 11 grand
and we're good no no daddy we're talking
millions upon millions of dollars to
shoot those fighter scenes of course
dude and how about this spoiler alert in
three two one right before the movie
starts tom cruise every bit of 50 you
can see on his face sitting down goes
hey just want you guys hope you guys
enjoy this movie i remember that it was
made for the and you're like what does
that mean i know because it was made for
the theater these are real g-forces
these are real fighter planes we did
this for you guys enjoy it's like wow
that's nice
they were in this weird rant about
scientology signing up for it wait what
and then now i'm part of scientology so
that's cool all right yeah man so that's
cool but uh yeah the movie is [ __ ] god
damn man it's usa usa usa
i wonder if they i was thinking about it
i wonder if they're gonna play it in
russia i don't think so right now
because russia is the enemy in that like
do they do a different edit for russia
like russia dude they didn't even
mention it that's how the movie was so
they didn't mention who the enemy was
but we all know who the enemy was oh no
they said rush at one point i didn't
hear it oh yeah i know i heard it okay
very clearly yeah it's when they're
doing the breakdown in the beginning
like how dangerous the mission is okay
and they tell you where it's at like
russia oh that makes all the sense but i
wonder if russia's like eat cool cool
movie and we love tom cruise russia
loves him sometime cruz do you mind if
we just edit a little bit with the
storyline so instead of russia can we
make tom cruise russian blown up america
like hard pass so i wonder for
the russia edition i'd love to get a
copy of that i wonder if he's like
attacking north korea or china you know
but then you go to china they don't play
that [ __ ] either
but i would assume the market's bigger
in china so china's gonna let the russia
[ __ ] even though they're boys they're
besties i'm they're in their myspace top
three i'm assuming that china is gonna
be cool with the russia propaganda on
that and it's a fictional movie so is it
though pretty real to me dude
pretty real to me
god what a [ __ ] movie it was fun oh
for sure my word
my word got some cam on today daddy
i need to get the dodger or the the best
jersey that does the
memorial day or like uh celebrating the
military is the padres
is such a military town that's also
where top gun takes place but um i need
to get the padres new uh military jersey
i have it i forgot it today this one
works this is cleveland this is the old
school one before they got all woke says
the indians yeah
crazy
anyway um
other than that top gun go see it man
it's so goddamn good shout out to miles
teller um top gun's fantastic then also
there's a little fight on saturday night
um
yeah javonte davis versus roland
rondo
romero i just call him romero
romero talked a lot of [ __ ] right uh
talked so much trash and so that fired
javante davis up
and i don't think people realize i i
knew i got a sense of it because i
worked at showtime for several years
that how much showtime is invested in
making javante davis a star
and you know he's a smaller guy so even
though floyd was a smaller guy he got
the level where you know he's undeniable
and you were paying to watch him lose or
win but you paid when floyd mayweather
fought so javonte davis is damn near
there now you think he's defended the
title ten times multiple different
weight classes the difference between
him and floyd mayweather is you're
talking about
possibly
there's argument for sure
the best knockout artist in boxing
period there's argument the best
knockout artist in combat sports period
at that small weight class and his
knockouts aren't like
you know
here and finishes them off
you're talking about
highlight reel
ko's going viral if you get knocked out
by him you're a meme in the next three
minutes all over
uh the internet his knockouts are so
[ __ ] vicious
i put this on right i love javante davis
horrible interview but i put this on
and uh i've i've watched uh romero
before
and i thought it was too much too soon
for him but obviously davis needs
opponent stuff like that but i was like
yeah it's a little much from
and he's you'll see
in previous fights he's very unorthodox
crazy knockout power i think the the
odds were this fight was going to be
under six rounds somebody's getting
knocked out just and then he promised
like i'm gonna get him out there in the
first round and knock him out in the
first round talks all this [ __ ] about
javonte davis this was at the barclays
center in brooklyn
they set a record for uh gate attendance
that's how big of a deal uh
javonte is so they set a a gate
attendance record think about all the
fighters they've had there deontay
wilder i was there in person cage side
ringside uh you know the the brooklyn
next they have huge huge
headliners there and javante davis set
the all-time live gate record that's how
big of a deal is when they announce uh
romero he hits booed like [ __ ] crazy
he's a las vegas kid javonte davis which
is hometown was baltimore if you didn't
realize that by the giant baltimore
tattoo on his back now you know
so
he gets a standing ovation the crowd
goes nuts
romero promised he was get he'd get him
out in the first round
it was all hype he's everything was
calculated because they both respect
each other's power and that first round
ends and they're both feeling each other
out the first round ends and davis they
call the bell gets in his face goes what
the [ __ ] happened the first round
where's all that energy thought you can
get me on the first round i was like oh
interesting
and
then uh javonte davis they show his mom
on the screen in between rounds and
she's dancing you know doing her thing
and he's he's yelling mom mom like
in the middle of coaches giving him
instructions yeah mom i like having fun
i'm like
interesting and then the next round he's
talking and he he didn't say who it was
i'd love to figure out who it was
clearly a celebrity was going get him
out of get him out of there and
jovante tells him in real time in the
middle of the fight goes not yet
not yet he's not he's not ready yet he
hasn't been cooked yet and javonte knew
that this kid was
he throws there's no setups everything's
such bad intentions he's such a [ __ ]
savage but he was so wound up tight he
was so tight that's where the experience
of
uh javonte davis comes in because he's
just being calculated he hits them the
kid did land a few shots nothing crazy
but you tell javanta dave's like right
this kid has a lot of power and respect
to respect it and i don't think he meant
to get him out of there i think it was
in the sixth round as fast as he did
because finally this kid lets loose and
he's throwing and just
walks into this hook dude
face for i'm dude i'm tired right i was
on xanax i'm here in one eye like this i
can't have
insomnia so i took his xanax one eye
open like come on javonte get him out
there dude it was a grenade the kid runs
into this hook
whack and the whole crowd goes [ __ ]
nuts dude highlight reel knockout yeah
i'm i would love to hear the argument
the better knockout artist in combat
sports ufc bellator one championship
boxing straight up knockout artist dude
you look at his record especially being
as light as he is and the fashion that
he knocks these dudes out again it's not
double jab right hand i'm talking it is
mortal kombat finish him
boom dude
like watch this one
here we go so this is from show time
boxing's twitter shout out to showtime
boxing miss you guys in previous fights
we've seen that yeah he seems kind of
awkward he starts opening up here
this dude's out out he's undefeated
never been dropped nothing
he is out on his look at him get up
i don't like how the camera followed him
after the knockout
to
the
locker room they like following the
entire way it's like dude let me do his
thing that sucks then javonte davis
gets on the mic
and he's like what's next he's like you
know anyone he they were talking about
um uh garcia ryan garcia they're talking
about all these other fights and say i'm
ready any time and he goes there's no
safety on this glock i get all the
ammunition and the the inside the ring
announcer goes uh i don't think he meant
that like the the nation is dealing with
a tough time with that reset mass you
know shooting at the school
so but you can tell that's not what
dave's where he it's not he didn't mean
to do that but
you know that knockout was
fabulous
take my money i dude i didn't watch the
uh
i saw a little bit of the co-main event
the guy like you straight out of [ __ ]
gangs in new york with the mustache this
guy from ireland he's getting beat up uh
by lara tough fight for him i saw just
two rounds of that but i already paid 80
bucks just to watch the main event
because i knew there was gonna be a
knockout javonte davis equals knockouts
the name of name name a more exciting
boxer right now
there's not a lot of them dude there's
just not
he has [ __ ] dynamite in his hands
what's interesting about him is you know
he's been a showtime guy forever
when they were doing
the countdowns you know they do the
countdowns for for the for the fight
leaning up the fight i forget who he's
fighting maybe cruz or whatever that
knocked against cruz
what
anyway so they were doing the countdown
and he you know he lives in baltimore
and it's late at night it's the only
time that the staff of showtime's like
oh this is too dangerous like he lives
in such a hoodie area like this is we
got to turn around man like i guess
you're just saying juventus yeah you're
fine if you're me they're like no we're
not like no you're with me you're fine
they're like it's the only time they've
shut down they're about they've been to
mexico juarez they've been everywhere
baltimore which i'm there pretty soon
here i think the end of july i'm in
baltimore but um probably not where
javante dave is from either but i would
go there august 4th through the 6th i'm
in baltimore shout out to javonte davis
um but it's the only time the the
countdown crew was like we're gonna
we're gonna lay low on this one and they
have to come back and shoot the next day
in the daylight
all right kids before we get into this
tj
dillashaw interview a few housekeeping
notes keep the lights on the thick boys
studio portland i will see you next week
thursday through saturday is portland
oregon that's june 9th through the 11th
get your tickets at thickboy.com and
then after san francisco at the cops
comment club june 17th through june 18th
friday saturday only come get some whole
new hour it's the all-new trash panda
summer tour and it starts in portland
next week baby next thursday friday
saturday come get some morgan
um that's portland oregon okay be cool
man but if you can tell they're like god
brandon i thought you had insomnia i
thought you have anxiety can't sleep
well i'm sleeping a lot better because
my mattress and i just don't have any
old regular mattress that's built for
everybody else this mattress was made
for me that's right my friends at helix
sleep they had me take a little quiz it
took just two minutes to complete then
it matched my thick body with the
perfect mattress just for me
so for you guys out there sleeping on
these general ass mattresses do you
sleep on your back your side your
stomach sleep hot cold whatever it is
helix got you covered man they have a
specific mattress that's made for each
of your thick bodies all right don't
take my word for it helix was awarded
the number one best overall matches 2019
in 2020 20 by gq and wired magazine
helix sleep was even award the number
one best overall overall mattress pick
of 2019 2020 by gq and wired magazine
the only beds i have in my house are
helix sleep mattresses i can't get rid
of my in-laws my family my freaking
parents grandma grant everybody wants to
sleep at my house i thought it's because
i was so friendly it's not because i
have the best mattresses and if you want
the same type of sleep the same type of
people always want to crash at your crib
just go to helixsleep.com
take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they will match you with a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life guaranteed son they
have a 10 year warranty and you get to
try it for 100 nights risk free if you
don't love it they'll pick it up for you
but you're gonna love it don't worry
about that helix is offering you guys up
to 200 off all mattress orders and free
pillows for the listeners at
helixsleep.com
slash shop s-h-a-u-b that's helix
sleep.com for up to 200 off
goodnight sleep sweet prince
all right let's take a little break from
me ranting about top gun and
baseball jerseys and freaking flaming
hot cheetos and
whatever hell else i'm talking about
because i have a very special guest he
is my brother from another mother a very
a way more competitive mother it is one
of the best
to ever do it it is the king it is tj
dillashaw who i absolutely love i saw my
song he's coming off surgery and i got
very drunk on fight campaign one of my
favorite companions of all time so let's
uh toss it to my boy tj dillashaw who is
on zoom on this on this holiday man if
there's one guy i know who's like me who
doesn't take breaks it is tj dillashaw
hashtag no breaks
let's do it hashtag no days off for tj
dillashaw uh where are you at like are
you currently in orange county where are
you at yeah i'm in southern california
orange county york linda
and uh
i guess
for you it's a little dicey i mean you
know obviously i'm not trying to break
news or [ __ ] [ __ ] like that but your
fight against al james sterling for the
world title uh it hasn't been announced
i assume july august september-ish
yeah it's definitely been some talks you
know i'm that's just that's what's up up
next you know i mean you can't uh go and
call me out like that and then try to
run from it so it's uh definitely gonna
be happening um you know on the right
man for the job it's just about figuring
out when now
yeah so as far as you not having the
exact date maybe having a general idea
of those three like summerish months
training right now you're not in
full-blown camp now i know you you're a
guy that's always training always in
shape super disciplined but you're not
in full-blown camp right now
no man i'm not going i'm not killing
myself right i'm still doing you know
some days i'll be i'll do two a day just
to do it most of the time it's like
working out once a day and still taking
the days off during the week
um keep keeping my body ready so when we
do get that announcement i don't have to
worry about getting in shape i'm already
in shape now it's just continuing the
game plan and really just kind of focus
on the actual fight skills rather than
be worried about getting in shape you
know when you're 36 years old you got to
stay in shape you can't you can't let
your body uh take a break and hibernate
because it takes forever to come back
yeah so i tell these young kids like i
had uh patty pimlin on uh food truck the
other week and i when i walked up and i
love patty i don't know if you've met
patty he's such a positive like
talented human being as far as like
entertainment value he's the only
fighter i've ever had on the show or any
athlete for that matter who he'll rip a
promo instead of doing it at me he will
he'll know which cameras his camera and
do it to the camera i'm like holy [ __ ]
dude so he's just but he was so big and
i told him off-camera go bubba i i love
what you're doing you're one of the best
real i know here's the thing though you
getting this big and then cutting down
getting big gun down when you're young
it's fine right now but as you go on
dude i'm telling you this isn't the way
to do it he's laughing you know but
he'll learn man he'll learn
yes
he's just loving diabetes
that's like a recipe for just like
destroying your body
and uh you know i mean he he's
i guess that's one thing when i look at
it right like they can promote him the
right way i do all this good stuff and
he's got some um stuff to grow and get
into
to higher echelons of the ufc but
i mean if you keep that same work ethic
that he has now he'll never be a
champion you know what i mean like you
can't
you can't have that downtime like that
you can't get that fat you can't be out
of shape i mean to not i mean you could
just it just kind of proves like the
dedication to what you need to do and no
not trying to like you know count on
them or anything but that's something
he's got to figure out with age right um
he's young
he's young yeah he's young you're out
like a great full-time job bro this
isn't yeah
you know wanting to be a fighter like
you have to be a fighter yeah
and i i do
the reason why i'm not worried about him
is because you know off camera you do
get the
the general idea he knows he's like i
know i know like i'm on it trust me i'm
on it right now i'm having fun i'm not
fighting top 15 guys i know i know the
the only other other guy kind of that i
know who's similar to you as far as
dedication is cheeto vera cheeto's a guy
dude he's just so disciplined man yeah
yeah he's uh always putting in the miles
you know get to wins back into the gym i
just think it's because what i mean you
know especially like me in the early
days it's like he loves what he does
yeah i agree he's uh that's who he
identifies himself as and that's what he
loves to do he's getting some fame right
now and uh doing very good with it and
so it makes you addicted to being
someone you know yeah and he deserves it
man and so do you brother when you talk
about
deserving
you know last time i saw you came on cal
bass fight companion it was straight off
the surge and i told you you know you
had that corey santa hagan fight which
was a huge fight in your career
you do work you beat him on one arm one
[ __ ] leg it was insane
and then
i hit you up before that i was like hey
what if you know depending on this fight
goes you want to do the fight pain
you're like i'm in dude and then i have
to fight your eyes you know blown up
your knees [ __ ] blow up like hey dude
you don't have to come like hell no i'll
make it man you come and you know get a
little tipsy it was one it's literally
i'm saying before you can it's one of my
favorite fight companions ever you just
having such a good time man i think it
was a good way for you to kind of just
relax and get away from all that
[ __ ] you were three comics basically
getting hammered so it was a good time
dude yeah you got to enjoy the process
too right we can't just like uh like i
do get addicted to being the best and
working my ass off and doing all that
stuff but at the same time you got to
enjoy it right and you got to enjoy the
lights and you got to enjoy the
interviews you got to enjoy the walk out
you can't be so nervous or so anxious
about it all that um you forget about it
right because then yeah what's the point
of me doing all this [ __ ] if i can't
soak it up a little bit you know so i
agree we've gone there and you know i've
been off for two and a half years on a
suspension getting a big win against san
hagan i'll bust it up it was fun for me
to come in there and
and to uh
see [ __ ] i'm still on the top
you know hell yeah you know
i'm still here yeah i'm proud of you man
i think uh
you know everyone everyone's getting
entitled to their own opinion i get it i
i think with you
you know there's nothing
that especially america loves more than
a comeback story and your your thing is
it's like with everything going on you
know this cancer culture and all this
[ __ ] going on and people want to cancel
people for everything or you know hang
it over their heads if they make mistake
for you it's like all right guy made a
mistake he paid his dues and lost
millions upon millions of dollars
millions of [ __ ] dollars yeah he paid
his dues i don't think people realize
that like when you're at that level
which you're at not being able to fight
for two years you're talking about
millions of dollars dude millions of
[ __ ] dollars so you miss out on all
that money you serve your time
you come back you come back and you
fight a guy and [ __ ] corey
sanderhagen who you know aurora kid i
[ __ ] love that kid i've known him
since he was 16. i love corey and for
you to do what you did in that fight on
one leg
i feel like it's almost
it's undeniable it's like all right dude
tj served his time you guys can keep
focusing on that
or you can move the [ __ ] on and now he's
fighting these monsters after two year
layoff
and trying to get to a title shot like
how
how people don't vibe with that which i
think the majority do online obviously i
mean the the [ __ ] boys are the ones
going to be talking right like all these
[ __ ] boys want to keep someone down
that's what that's what they do right
i mean that's just that's inevitable
especially the cancer culture that
you're talking about today like it's
just going to be talk if there's
something to bring you down about
they're gonna do it right yeah whatever
it is yeah
like if you're if you're a guy that
tells me you haven't made a mistake i
don't [ __ ] trust you no i mean yeah
or or you're just living a boring ass
life you know like in order to shoot for
the moon you gotta
land on the stars or you want to land on
the moon but sometimes you know you make
[ __ ] mistakes as part of the game but
you know i just think your story should
be so inspirational you know what i'm
saying like what you're doing is nuts
man
and how how do you how do you
i'm sure going through all this you've
come out a different person you'd have
to i think anybody who goes through any
adversity if they don't come out the
other end a better person you're just a
narcissist and there's probably a reason
why white people don't [ __ ] with you so
for you you you've had to come out a
different person i'm sure you've
realized who you can trust who you know
who can put your your
trust into you know what i'm saying and
just kind of i'm sure your team now is
tighter than ever is that fair to say
100 percent change to this uh situation
right um learn to identify as something
other than just the ufc champion right
right
that's my whole identity right just
working my ass off winning the belt
that's what i did that's how i made
money that's how i fed my family how i
kept the roof over my head
um being out for those two years like
you said losing and all that opportunity
and making money um i found out that i
would be just fine outside doctor and
i'm just fine not being a fighter
because i'm going to take that same
determination and set it into an income
with other with other endeavors you know
other other jobs and other ways to
um
identify myself to be honest right like
uh the friends i surround myself with
the family i got and then uh
yeah man i mean the the income i'm able
to make
through all these other ventures has
just been actually quite a big stress
reliever because i mean
you know being in this work you've been
in the ufc for 12 years you guys started
thinking like damn what am i going to do
when i'm done yeah i know right like i
know when i turn it up like i don't have
to fight right now yeah i'm doing it
because i want to get my belt back and
make a statement i don't need to do it
yeah i think
i don't know if you would have gotten
this far outside the outgun with your
other business adventures unless you
were forced to because you're so
obsessed with fighting and being the
best it's tough to step out and go oh
i'm still gonna be the best but i need
to focus on this other stuff i think
it's kind of it's weird to say this
after all the [ __ ] you've been through
but look where you're at now it's like
it was a blessing it really was man it
was a blessing it was a [ __ ] up
blessing for sure the dude the worst the
worst of the worst you know but you know
you've come out the other side and look
at you man and you know fighting al
jermaine sterling for for a world title
um
it's just and you know it wasn't like
you know you'll hear guys again
these anybody any fighters whatever you
know say oh you know they're giving this
to him it's like
you know he took two years off and then
fought corey sanderhagen who was a
[ __ ] surging superstar still is i
think corey
not right now he has some things to
learn but eventually he when you're out
of there corey's next in line bubba
ko i believe in corey a-town's finest so
for yeah in all my interviews right like
i think he's a very dangerous fighter as
soon as he can get a little bit more
around it and fix some of those holes in
his game um
he's a guy that is a dangerous fight
right he's a
he's a straight killer um
and he's figured out his mind too right
i think that was his biggest downfall
when i was out there training was he
didn't quite believe in himself yet he's
doing that um but now he's got to kind
of a little bit revenge reinvent himself
but yeah he's uh
you know all those guys that want to
talk [ __ ] but i don't deserve it
i tell him go fight san hagen
yeah like
no
yeah tj i'll do one better i'm gonna cut
you off here yeah go fight corey
sandhagen and blow out your knee
do it with one leg you morons let me
know it goes for you i'll tell you how
it goes he knocks out or he finishes you
that's how it goes dude so
that narrative does it doesn't make
sense in any in the actual reality of
what's going on it's like you've walked
through this [ __ ] fire not only to
mention
before getting suspended the amount of
work you've put in to earn this
you know everything you have and then
you get corey sanderhagen who's a
nightmare you beat him on one leg knife
find out jermaine sterling
to you
when you look at al jamaine sterling you
look at peter yan were you surprised how
that fight went down especially being
the rematch because i'll be honest dude
before you answer
i love al joe
he's a phenomenal athlete but he's a
monster
[Music]
i've never been
i should say this i i gotta be careful i
was never sold on peter yan for a long
time i just i just wasn't right i'm boys
with you i'm boys with corey i just i
just wasn't sold on him and then the
first fight even though he you know got
dq'd i was like oh this motherfucker's
the real deal this dude is talented and
i thought in the rematch he was just
gonna do the same thing and walk through
algo you know were you surprised by that
by that fight did you predict it or what
are we talking about here i think most
of us thought that young was gonna run
through him right i mean it's hard not
to when you watch that first fight
because
you know not only was he beating he was
ragdoll yeah like made him look like a
little [ __ ] in wrestling like yeah
wrestling big time
um
you know and john's one of those guys
that has all of his basics are pretty
tight right
um
but i think we all forgot you know why
al jo is where he's at because he's got
some dangerous things he's got some ways
to implement his game um and so yeah
before the fight that's how i was
thinking but i want to go back and watch
it um there's a lot of things that
surprised me about yon and how he
he's not willing to adapt in the middle
of a fight
right that first round lost in the fight
um because
he's thought he's a slow starter he
likes to wear you out he likes to stalk
you down and get your timing right sure
yeah won that round just by landing
kicks and obviously you know that algo
won the next two rounds because of uh
yawn giving up his back
but that's where i was surprised man
like especially after the second round
right okay whatever happened one round
but then when you go back out and you do
the exact same [ __ ] thing and you
yeah he's going to get a takedown right
you stuck 22 of them but he got two of
them but those two takedowns he got you
completely just gave up your back and
you know that's his only strength and
then we'll talk about i mean for one
that's giving your backup right that
might [ __ ] happen right that's it's
gonna happen he's gonna get in the back
he obviously just to a lot of [ __ ]
guys right he dictates that pace
but then to see that he didn't know had
any idea of how to get out of it right
he was like in survival mode just
defending the choke he was taking the
triangle the wrong way he wasn't doing
anything to get out of it like
you know um
he just
in his coaches i mean after the second
round was telling him like hey do not
give up your back like just don't do it
and then he gave up this back in the
first minute it just it just baffled me
that guy on top like that isn't able to
make changes you got to be so
well-rounded in this game right now that
not only are you a different fighter
from fight to fight but you can be a
different fighter from round around and
that you're able to adjust to what
needed because game plans never go the
way you want to you can have something
as much as you want yeah most of the
time that [ __ ] always changes in the
middle of a fight and you got to be able
to adapt like that you know and i think
that's what separates you guys who do
become the tip of the spare world
champions or you know even the top three
that kind of separates those guys you
know you look at
you know i think we saw a little bit of
it in gilbert burns hamzat fight where
you know gilbert at rose to the top he's
that what number two guy in the world
but
it you know i had him on future
gilbert's one of the nice guys in the
world but
i think part of the problem there is
he never adapted to hamza was willing to
exchange be this gunslinger just make it
a freaking fight it was a dog fight
upper echelon guys like yourself you
know uh i could name a million guys i'm
not going to but the the tip of the
spirit guys adjust go oh you wanna make
this a dog fight and play this rock em
sock em robots
i'm down for it in pockets but i'm gonna
you i'm gonna be the smarter fighter
take you down know when to do it and
you'll find certain guys like justin
gates who's also willing to be that
gunslinger it's like at a certain point
you get to the very top echelon guys
they know what you're doing man and then
they and they change the approach
whether the game plan was you know to
exchange or whatever they change it so
they're winning rounds that's money in
the bank and that's what i think
separates you top level guys is those
guys who are willing to adjust from
round around like maybe your entire game
plan
uh in training camp was you know to be
lie on your feet not you know not
exchange or not implement so much
wrestling but
[ __ ] happens he's coming forward once we
begin all right now we're gonna start
taking him down winning rounds using our
grappling so
i just i find it
i don't say baffling but you can see
like certain times there's a reason why
you were a champ there's a reason why uh
israel assani is this reigning champ you
can just see it's like oh they're
adapting like they had an idea going
into it and they're adapting in real
time round by round because they have
the skill set to adjust to whatever's
going on
yeah i mean it's a lot of work to uh
be able to do that right so you have to
work on things maybe you're not good at
or you have to be able like there's
certain things that got you where you're
at and once you start drinking that
kool-aid it's like [ __ ] that's who i am
right so i'm gonna win these fights i'm
gonna do it but not every fight goes
that way and so you gotta you gotta work
on those weaknesses or work on you know
with the what-ifs or you know say you
[ __ ]
you know um a couple of fights that i
have where i had to change myself up
completely was like uh going into the
first garbrandt fight you know um he was
really hard for me to
set [ __ ] up on that first round he was
really fast and he was using that
distance distance control and got out of
the way
um you know i got dropped into that
first round so i sat down the corner
dwayne's like hey man i'll stop setting
everything up
every time you think he's out of the way
right so yeah he's running and then your
combo is not working which is blast the
kick
you know and so i come out that second
round and instead of me doing what i was
doing that first round i switched my
timing up and you know i've been going
to the body that whole first round and
blast him upstairs and kick and then it
kind of changes the whole time of the
fight um you know then the san hagen
fight you know the fight would have been
a lot more like that first round if i
wouldn't have blown my knee out right
yeah get that fight to the ground um but
then i had to start using my clinch i
had to start using you know leg kicks i
started using different i couldn't even
use my footwork right um so there's
different things that i had to do and
that one was a [ __ ] up situation
because i had to do it i didn't have no
choice you have no choice whatever it
takes to win the fight you know you look
at francis and gano sarah gone
you know francis came in the same with
you blown out knee you know but it was
like man i have to take the fight like i
got to figure out a way to get this done
he's by no means a world-class grappler
dude
[ __ ] look like you out there he's
shooting mixing it up shooting get him
down just winning rounds it was the most
exciting fight but he was like i got one
leg dude i got i have to figure out what
whatever it is to win these [ __ ]
rounds money in the bank i don't care
about being exciting i don't care that
the game plan was to knock him out i
gotta wrestle this dude on one [ __ ]
leg and he got it done man that's the
difference with you with you upper
echelon guys like it's whatever it takes
you have the skill set
even if it's not your strong suit you're
gonna figure out a way to get it done
when you look at uh you mentioned cody
garbrett when you look at
how things have gone for him i love cody
when you look at are you surprised by it
uh
yes and no
you know because yes because he's uh
he's a pretty freak athlete man like
he's eight he's like fast he's the the
fastest guy i've ever or sparred or
fought
uh by far the most speed you know um so
explosive yeah just crazy but
and i'm not trying to be a complete
[ __ ] but he's he's not the smartest
human being inside that cage right like
like his fight iq you mean yeah he's not
willing to i mean
you know i just mean
all around general you should be like
like the whole point we're talking about
being able to stay on the top is you got
to change who you are
and fight to fight the fight he's the
exact same fighter right yes i mean he's
a wrestler you know how to wrestle yeah
why not learn some [ __ ] jiu-jitsu and
you know stop relying on your chin and
hands because your chin is not there you
know yeah so change up who you are as a
fighter
and um
he's just not willing to do that he's
just going to keep his head in the same
spot his hands are going to be low and
he's going to throw hard fast hooks you
know and so after everyone kind of sees
like where his weaknesses are at you
know his left hand is in his pocket as
it goes the right hand just keep your
left hand high and smoke them with the
right i mean game over right they've
seen it like five fights in a row yeah
and eventually he's gonna be like all
right man you know like
yeah i hate to see you give him a fight
to where you know yaya's never knocked
out anyone in 40 fights so it should be
um
should hopefully go in his favor for
this one you know yeah hopefully he gets
the knockout i think with him too it's
like you know former champ that version
of cody garbrandt when he fought
dominick cruz i was like jesus christ
dude this kid is unreal
and then with the ch you know i think
cody's thing is he has so much fight in
him he's so full of piss and vinegar he
has so much fight if you do get one on
him you connect on him it's he's look he
sees red and he has he just for him i
think
i figured you know losing three in a row
or whatever it is would make him realize
okay i can't do this with these top guys
but
there's just something in him though the
way he's his in his dna where he sees
red and he just wants to throw caution
in the wind and play this game and when
you're fighting those top guys
you know it's it's going to be [ __ ]
tough man i hate to see it i hate to see
it man
it's a bummer but i i'll hopefully
figure it out you know with the fight
they gave him with uh ronnie you know
like you said he's not dangerous too
right but on the ground one of the best
ever i think garbrandt's too fast for
that [ __ ] i think he's he's government's
hard to take down he's gonna be too fast
and yaya stand up is um very pathetic
yeah it's not great i mean 40 fights and
no finishes on your feet you know yeah
uh but his ground he's a ninja i just
don't think he's gonna be able to get it
there i think i think garbrandt's too
fast for it agree i think garbrandt gets
a ko and gets back on pat on the right
path hopefully
uh speaking again on the right path i
mean you're on the right path so when
you look at al joe how do you see this
fight going down because correct me if
i'm wrong here
i think
peter yan is a more difficult matchup
for you stylistically am i off on that
oh
yeah no just i mean i guess i mean i
think it's more of a dangerous fight yes
right like al james not a dangerous guy
whatsoever right he's just one of those
guys that he's going to put you into
quicksand and try to get you into his
game right which is you know a different
beast in its own
right but fortunately for enough i can
wrestle i got good jiu jitsu my cardio
is second to none so correct that game
ain't gonna work on me and then um
you know i really don't believe in a
stand-up whatsoever um to where a guy
like yon
he is you know
very dangerous but he's definitely got
his openings as well too with
his high guard and his
flat feet and things like that too so
they both i mean
they both have a way to fight them right
and that's kind of what i was talking
about earlier is that you got to change
from fight to fight you know i'm really
good at watching tape with dwayne and
figuring out how i'm going to fight
someone
um and try to be a different fighter
every time i come out there at least at
least you can't be completely different
but
you know try to i mean because i'm so
well-rounded i can do every every aspect
that's a great really try to dictate
that's how i want to win
yeah i think
you know and and cheeto vera said this
use on food truck it drops i think
wednesday or thursday when we're
dropping this we had a cheeto vera on
food truck and it drops this wednesday
and i was asking about you and uh al joe
and he thinks you're gonna win but he
was saying that
the difference is is he you know he
thinks like you're a fighters fighter
he's like tj is a fighters fighter and
with algo he's an athlete that got into
fighting
which i relate to
pretty heavy because i was an athlete
gun fighting's not in my blood i'm not
aggressive dude i didn't enjoy hurting
people i didn't i was competitive and i
viewed it as a sport but
my thing was is i was an athlete that
fell into this i'd much rather catch
footballs or tell dick jokes on stage it
was like getting punched in the face was
not fun for me i never enjoyed it so he
was saying with with al joe the
difference is he's gotten so far because
he's such a good athlete
and he's some the things that he does he
does very well
but at the end of the day if he gets
behind on a round or it's not going his
way he just doesn't have that dog in him
that's what cheeto said he doesn't have
that dog in him that me and tj have
yeah i think that's very true you know
i'm more of a fighter that became an
athlete i was seriously like bred for
this
on accident right just having a very
competitive family and you know having
two brothers and a very aggressive
family i think i'm just uh i'm mean you
know
yeah
i don't i don't like i really want to
because i don't feel like i'm mean
outside of competition no um if it gets
into competition man i'm gonna [ __ ]
i'm gonna go you can do whatever it
takes
i don't i don't really care what's gonna
happen to me you know so yeah um it's
where i feel like that's you know a
little bit different a lot of guys might
say because that's a nerve-wracking
[ __ ] sport man you're going in there
to you know throw some baseball bats at
people's heads with your shoes
you know trying to knock someone out and
become a highlight reel right so
um
yeah it's a [ __ ] unique sport and i'm
just
not i'm not worried about it you know
i'm a gunslinger that can use my brain
you know correct which is a problem for
a lot of guys i think and this is
you know a compliment i think to the
fullest is
you know we had my head coach was lisa
bowling who's this little ball of fire
and he's the wrestling coach for gsb for
myself rashad shane carowind justin you
justin gaichi so and he would tell me
he's like you know i was out of the
sport by the time he came around uh in
in denver and stuff like that
and me and lisa talk once a week and
he's like dude i've never seen somebody
eat in wrestling
mma whatever the [ __ ] sport it is he
goes i've never seen somebody more
competitive than tj dillashaw he's like
i'm telling you dude there's like it's
like this you know i told him i'm like
he's almost like a kobe bryant it's like
this mamba mentality goes i'm telling
you dude you've never seen anything like
it and he's like he's like i'm obsessed
with it he's so so [ __ ] vicious dude
if somebody gets something over on him
he will do what he will go as many
rounds as it takes to get that back and
when i heard that i i'll just never
forget in this least this guy lisa
bullon for the viewers that don't know
him is he does not give compliments he
is not
he's such a such a savage man he's such
a savage
and for him to talk about a fighter this
way i was like holy [ __ ] dude it fires
me up man and i you know going to that
corey san diego fight he was telling me
he's like dude dj is sleeping at my in
my wrecking wrestling room
he makes fun of me you know i'm a world
champion that can afford like
you know a nice place to go and stay out
i was doing my camp back and forth every
every wednesday i'd fly to colorado and
i'd fly back on saturday you know did my
grappling and my wrestling here did most
of my striking there with dwayne and um
but i would go he's got this little
locker room with like you know twin size
bunk beds in there it's kind of like
something glorious i mean it's a nice
spot right i'm going wrong it's a really
really dope spot but you know i'm just
i'm driving around a little tiny ford
ranger piece of [ __ ] for ranger in the
80s like
you know probably shouldn't be getting a
place to play staying in a locker room
but
you know it's not why i'm i mean i'm
just there to get better
and did you do that to kind of humble
yourself and like go back to your roots
like what when i hear like you sleep in
in the wrestling room you renting this
piece of [ __ ] truck or maybe you own
that piece of [ __ ] ranger
is it is that so you don't like get too
big for your britches like what's you
know because you could be going around
in a freaking ferrari if you wanted to
you know but you decided to do this 1980
ford ranger and sleep on the mat you
could be at the four seasons of ferrari
and still get the training in my man
i don't know man i feel like uh i'm
trying to just be smart with my money
man i got a four-year-old kid
um you know most of my income was coming
in from fighting and so i think
because that's the way i started and i
like i said i have income coming out
elsewhere but i started out being a
fighter and i was always the guy that
was nervous that it could always end yep
the guy that like dude this [ __ ]
glory road can end at the same time i
don't want to be one of those stories of
these professional athletes that had it
all that just let it go
um so i don't know i mean
i don't know i don't think it's
purposely to try to ground myself it's
more just i'm just tight-ass yeah
also not being stupid with your money
you know it's also that yeah with with
and you do you just have the one uh boy
four-year-old boy yeah one four-year-old
boy yeah we're trying to have another we
have one right now i was gonna say let's
get going man you know nobody likes an
only child they grow up weird practice
is the best part
practice
we're trying a lot dude you need you
need to take that competitive edge that
you have into the bedroom dude let's get
going here man your wife's like what's
up dog what are we doing here man let's
go you're supposed to be mr competitive
right
do you see similar traits in your in
your four-year-old as far as that
competitive you know i think
you know i got it for i had an older
brother like you'll see
people that have that weird competitive
edge not like michael jordan [ __ ]
competitive edge but a lot of
guys and gals for that matter but a lot
of guys will have older brother older
siblings and that's where it really
harnesses that yes yes definitely comes
from the older brother um i i see him in
a little bit right because i rough
rounds with him i play with them and i
play games with him i don't let him win
you know what i mean like hell no never
beat his ass and he'd be like mad and
crying about it he's like that's how
he's going to get like a great exact
same attitude i want him to be mad about
losing you know what i mean like
these uh like okay but i don't want you
to be a poor sport to an extent but at
the same time i do
right like yeah i [ __ ] hate losing
yes pisses you off so bad you want to
beat my ass you know what i mean yeah
because i really feel that's what bred
my competitiveness because my brother
would just my older brother would just
beat me at things and just
rub my face making me funny about me and
this like
you know i was the middle child so he
got to whip my ass and then he'd be like
i'll beat your ass even more if you tell
mom
i couldn't tell mom you know and like it
was just like this and then i tried
doing it to my younger brother but my
younger brother was the baby so it
didn't really work out for me at that
end you know so i got all the ass opens
but i didn't get to kick no one's ass so
it like made me so angry about it that
uh i think it turned me into who i am
yeah what's up now big bro world
champion dog about to fight for another
one yeah i love it yeah i think
you know with with my son you know he's
six now he does jiu jitsu he excels at
jiu jitsu but whatever game we're
playing he'll lose and his mom like i
don't like the way he he hates lose i'm
like no no i like that he doesn't enjoy
when he loses i don't want to be like ah
it's okay because we i'm telling
whatever he does whether it's business
yeah hell no hell no there's no ice
cream bubba like
he his favorite ice cream is this place
right up the street and he knows if he
doesn't get 10 takedowns he doesn't get
ice cream so this dude goes nuts for his
10 takedowns and he'll get and look at
me and go yeah i'm like that's what i
need out of you dude
yes
and it's hard as a dad when he doesn't
get his 10 take down so he's like no ice
cream down like
no you know i feel bad
yeah i know i feel like such an [ __ ]
i don't know man i think you're doing
the right thing though you know what i
mean you do run obviously yeah it's hard
and i trust anything i want to spoil the
[ __ ] out of my kid right yeah man
it's like you got to create that
mentality that uh you got to work your
ass off to get what you want but i think
if we want a little tj dillashaw jr2
here we're gonna you need more kids man
i mean it worked for you it worked for
me anybody i know who's doing anything
had siblings to kind of
you know rub [ __ ] in their face man so
let's get take that take that work ethic
man bring in the bedroom you know what
i'm saying
yeah oh you're gonna get me in trouble
dude be too competitive now i know right
i love it it's like all right [ __ ]
challenge i'm getting it done
dude yeah she's a is that are you taking
vitamins and an iv before you have sex
yeah yeah [ __ ] that's exactly what
we're doing i'm taking all my
supplements and taking some cialis
like who's the guy in the corner that's
my sex coach okay
hell yeah doing some wim hof before yeah
doug get it done brother well man you
know you know who i'm rooting for
brother i can't
i just can't wait for you you know to
for this fight to get announced and
nobody works harder than you my brother
you nobody works harder than you ignore
the the negativity ignore the noise i
know you do you do a great job with it
and uh
the way you shut them up is by winning
man you know this better than anybody
brother so [ __ ] everybody keep doing
your thing man and you know who we're
rooting for for on this side and you
know after that after that big win you
get the belt you got to come back on
combat fight companion we'll share some
whiskey and we'll both get drunk this
time yeah bring the hardware let me let
me put the belt around my waist the
closest i'll ever get to the belt and
that's fine there's no problem with that
[ __ ] that right it's like uh like also
those two years off too you know i can't
see what life is outside of fighting i'm
like man shaw's got it down right
yeah how do you like being the best and
this shit's fun but [ __ ] it beats you up
you know to me i'm 36 years old you get
out of bed now yeah it's a lot of work
brother yeah
there's nobody better though man you
were born for this so i wish you nothing
but the best brother and i'll see you
soon next time we do this let's do it in
person we got you as soon as the fight's
announced let's get you out here on a
food truck man i'd love that just go
over the fight and everything man but oh
yeah i love you man keep kicking ass
keep being a killer ass dad and uh let's
have another baby man let's get going
i'm on it dude i'm on i'm gonna go right
now yeah
daytime that's when you know you're
getting older
all right brother take care man to easy
champ later brother there you have it
ladies and gentlemen more gentlemen than
ladies that's just the demo we know this
18 to 46 males what i specialize in
um yeah tj dillashaw won my face man one
of my absolute faves the kobe bryant of
the ufc the dude is a savage i'm so
excited for his fight hopefully it
happens you know
july might be a little too hopeful so
you're looking august september i assume
by september october at the very latest
price september hopefully you know but i
like his chances man such a [ __ ] great
story he's good dude yeah yeah
that'd be a great choice acting all
their chin got tatted up man you got
that half sleeve now i don't know what's
called the half sleeve or not it's just
like that'd be a half sleeve if it goes
up to there down yeah i want your
forearm down i want your opinion on this
too because i feel like this is so empty
yeah this area i'll fill that in okay
fill that in yeah don't do that
okay unless you're a stripper in
portland you got to fill that in all
right you feel me i think though
at least one big one yeah i think the
tiger but we'll see ooh i like that
daddy likes daddy likes speaking of
portland i'm there next week next
thursday through friday i'm in portland
also more strip clubs per capita than
anywhere else also the widest state in
the nation there you go do you know that
so yeah i'm in portland uh june 9th the
11th oh jay just had this
shop and friends with monsters that's
next wednesday june 8th
june 8th job and friends some very
special guests me and a bunch of
monsters
we always have special guests last
special guest was um
uh jim gaffkin oh [ __ ] yeah we had jim
gaffigan last time we've had uh
so many monsters but uh yeah next week
we also have another monster shop and
friends that's june 8th one show only
and then portland is next week as well
june 9th the 11th portland oregon i'll
be balls deep in voodoo donuts and
coffee that hipster coffee then san
francisco is june 17th through the 18th
at the cobbs and then just added fort
wayne indiana fort wayne indiana it's
actually where my uncle was born it's a
military area july 14th through 16th and
then san diego california is that the
laugh factory it's in the freaking smack
dab middle of san diego downtown that's
the laugh factory july 21st through the
23rd
and then javonte dave's hometown
baltimore maryland august 4th through
the 6th
so portland you're up next week let's
ride all right jim what do you got all
right first thing is brian ortega versus
yarya
on mexican team daddy
such a big fight for that featherweight
division such a big fight
i love this obviously i'm super biased i
absolutely love my boy brian ortega yeah
rodriguez we'll see man
talented kid yep talented kid but this
is a great freaking fight i'm in
it's a july 16th main event so it's a
fight night
uh go back to my tour dates right here
on the 16th
this july 16th yep fort wayne indiana
god damn it
all right it happened we'll figure it
out yeah it's a great fight though
definitely a great fight can't wait for
that one
all right so uh this one's a little
weird anthony smith was on his podcast
with you know he does the podcast with
michael bisping now no i didn't know
that oh so it's a brilliant idea yeah so
they're they're kind of like a duo and
it's called believe you me
oh so the same name as yeah before
exactly anthony smith is great he's
great but apparently he was telling a
story about his mom and i think his wife
were out of ufc when he was going to
fight jon jones i believe this is john
jones fight and then he said that dan
bilzerian and donald cerrone were both
drunk and they actually took their seats
away because they were in the front row
and they kind of like you know finagled
their way in there
and they took the seats away and then
also the mom said that dan bizern was
watching porn on his phone as well jesus
it was like this and they were both
drunk
so damn damn blizzarian and donald
cerrone responded
oh they both came out because it was a
tweet or what it would know so he said
on the podcast but then dan bilzerian i
guess he put this message he dm'd or
just messaged uh anthony smith somehow
so he said wait let me go up to here
here right here uh so the ufc says uh
we're [ __ ] taurus head off now this
is dancing you should at least try to
have some uh semblance of the truth in
there first off cowboy invited me to the
fight and he had the tickets i i didn't
ask anyone to move and certainly not
your mom i also didn't watch porn if she
was looking at my phone i'm sure what
she saw was a random snapchat from a
girl that turned out to be naked when i
opened it
and then he goes here he goes i don't
drink so i certainly wasn't hammered
your depiction of the story is complete
[ __ ]
um so that's essentially it then donald
cerrone uh like screenshot that and put
it on his instagram but then deleted it
afterwards too
i yeah i don't yeah listen i know donald
he's a great dude i don't know dan i i
don't know him in any facet obviously
there's some murky waters as far as his
background and money and all that stuff
i don't know him
man i i think maybe it's like there
there's the there's the truth right and
then there so there's dan's truth
there's anthony smith truth and there's
somewhere in the middle that's actually
what happened
but i do not think that anthony smith
would make this up
just don't he's not he's like [ __ ]
he has no reason to you know that's not
what he does so yeah i think from his
perspective that's how he sees it and
that's his narrative and maybe his mom
told him something that's her
perspective and dan has his perspective
and it's the miscommunication maybe we
should talk about it you know but
i definitely don't think anthony smith
would make this up there's some sort of
truth to it yeah probably sure yeah yeah
all right so that's more of just like a
rumor meal thing but this is pretty
crazy so edmund shabazzian he was always
with edmund tervardian and also ronda
rousey he finally split from them to go
to i think dominance m a mma with uh ali
abdulaziz oh interesting yeah so he says
now shahbazian has been that gym forever
ronda was talking about him years ago
how talented he is yep so he says i
needed a change it was time it was
definitely time for me it could have
been done sooner but now i'm just happy
to be here and get to work get the new
work in i've not talked to them since i
left from my end i have a good
relationship with them i don't have any
problem all respect because i respect
what they've done for me but on my end
i'm good i haven't talked to ronda and
say a few months i don't have anything
against her respect from my end as far
as my end he says and wait sometimes
i don't have any ill will nor should
they like you got to do what's best for
the fighter and if you actually care
about him and they he fasted
mentally if you know he's had a tough
streak like
all the talent in the world so
even though they brought him up and have
given him opportunity obviously the kid
put the work in so
if you actually care about the kid
who's a complete savage there's
something there's there's a disconnect
with his mentality going to that octagon
and then maybe it is the coaching maybe
what they're saying he's heard so many
times and this happened to me where
you're just like do you tell everybody
the same [ __ ] like this isn't this is
cookie cutter stuff so i don't i'm not
saying that but i
completely can say for a fact that
there's a disconnect between the
management the coaching and chabazian
there's something going on there he's
like this is the best move for me if
they care about him they go do your
thing man wish you the best good luck
yeah hopefully they and i'm sure they
i'm sure they look like that yeah
because he has all the talent for sure
he was amazing monster the last few
fights kind of was a bummer but yeah
super talented
alastair wolverine versus barahari
rubber match is going to be at uh glory
collision four and i think that's july
i'm in i'm into that yeah
i never mind gloria
match october 8th that's way further
okay far away yeah october 8th
yeah bona hari the bad boy of combat
sports yeah that's scary dude super
scary dude so patty pimplet versus our
boy
jordan levitt the freaking sugar in the
tank guy oh the sweetest he's good dude
he's like a legit fighter so that's
gonna be that's gonna be kind of crazy
july 23rd and we're in we're about to be
in june so patty has all that weight to
lose in about two
just seeing him on months truck i cannot
believe he can lose it from here to then
i root for him of course i i know it's
not very professional i love it his
attitude
you're going to find a big bigger patty
pinwheel fan than me i [ __ ] love that
kid he has all the tools man yeah not
the easiest fight no dude jordan's a
killer
i'll tell you who's the killer though
patty yeah don't get it twisted that's a
good this is a really good matchup but i
mean this is like probably his biggest
test so far you'll see
um
i think we've discussed this before how
caesar gracie said nick diaz in return
by the end of 2022 so nick diaz was on
tmz saying that he wants to return but
he wants to go straight for the title
against camaro he says he thinks he can
beat camaro
yeah it's tough coming off a loss like
he looked bad either taking all that
time off but remember all the rumors
circulating like he has to fight doesn't
want to be in there yeah obviously if it
is a money thing fighting kamar usman
would be the biggest
kind of poorest money move so
it makes sense he would want that i just
you know just skip all the mess i don't
need to go in there and get my ass with
by one of the young guys anyway and it's
not that i won't win it's just not
motivating to fight somebody that's i
want to fight for the title i'm 38 years
old yeah i think i'll beat him i would
love it if they gave me a shot i just
don't see the ufc doing that i don't
know what do you think as far as
it being a big big event though because
nikki is attached to it even though he
didn't look that great last year like
that great you know
nate is obviously the bigger draw yeah
even though you know nick someone who
started this whole thing um
yeah it's a tough sell on the ufc i i do
think camaro needs some of those big
fights
you know if he wants to but also the
welterweight division
right now you toss in a nick diaz it
gets even more complicated like you know
we had uh belial muhammadan uh food
truck
and
you know you you got leon edwards there
you got muhammad you got hamzat like the
there's other [ __ ] that like that
division needs to work itself out and
these guys have earned it so
for
nick to jump in there it just it just
delays everything i just don't see the
ufc doing it it makes it doesn't make a
ton of sense yeah
[Music]
yeah it'd be kind of weird if you did
that
uh so of course this one's in there
what's up no but this is interesting
because we thought you know korean
zombie might retire i thought he did
retire but the translator was like i'm
not going to say that i know but he was
considering it he said he just can't be
a champion he realized that which was
just you know that's a tough one but
yeah it's heartbreaking so he does want
to he wants to fight one more time
because you know he says his last fight
was not what he expected you know he
didn't do as well he's as he should so
one more fight
i like
him
ufc give him a nice send away he wants
it in korea too which would be dope
so that so that means that fight's not
taking place right now for a while okay
so we'll see you maybe in two years
maybe
um you wanna just do one more how do you
feel uh give me two more two more
oh this sucks so this guy was apparently
a hopeful the prospect for the ufc he
was a killer and then he this happened
during his fight at eternal mma did you
check a kick or something no he kicked
so i'll show you right here
happened early on now did he cut a bunch
of weight
i don't know
it happens early
[Music]
either cut a ton of weight right that
makes your bones pretty fragile or uh
that thing you already had small
fractures in it it was just ready to go
and just didn't happen in camp and then
just by looking at the draw you throw
that kick and it was ready to go anyways
probably what happened during camp but
didn't because you didn't practice again
and then that happens yeah a lot of
times it can be weight cut though he
threw a quick earlier two and looked
like he was like hurt by it so yeah it's
probably slowly just
went to [ __ ]
uh i don't follow nba but you know this
guy glenn big baby davis yeah lsu's
finest there you go he's going to fight
apparently on the undercard for jake
paul's fight on august 13th i believe it
is
why
yep august 13.
uh davis vs larry sanders who's larry
sanders
isn't that like a tv show
it is right
larry sanders
yeah but yeah i mean all right
that's what he wants to do you have the
chechnyan uh president going with hamzad
have you seen that oh they're rolling
right i don't have it as a current event
but i heard what and so did he tap him
out or something i mean you can tell
hamza is taking pretty like someone sent
to me is like dude look at hamza you
know because i'm high and humps out
there like look at hamza getting [ __ ]
up by the president of chechnya i
watched it and first of all he's it's
like a shark tank so he has all these
young killers coming after him and how's
that intel is messing around and then at
the very end the president of uh
chestnut jumps in there
and um
you know he's no punk you know it's
especially you know you think you do to
biden's not even funny but
you know
i want his strikings
but uh you know his grappling stuff is
pretty on point
he was just waiting for him
he's cheeked up too man
yeah look at him how's that just do just
that outfit on too gangster
is it a one piece
it does look like a one piece look at
him see look at homs that's not like
full bore here
it comes it's kind of messing around he
has gloves on too so it looks striking
so bad he's striking so bad
now you you know if you know anything
about chechnyan the way that chechen
leader runs things i'd like to see him
against a big strong gay dude
that'd be [ __ ] good gay dude with
some you know
little piss in his tank let's get going
here see how he
deals with that gay dude you know what
i'm saying fire that up i'd like to see
that
um since we're looking at grappling this
is khabib versus luke rockhold
[Music]
once you get you down he doesn't play by
the same rules as there's no rolling he
just breaks it
i just miss you
[Music]
i miss you
and luke rockhold is a savage on the
chest
[Music]
god dawg look at him just a [ __ ]
savage
dagger standing savage
[Music]
jesus christ
very very strong very talented well on
the food truck muhammad was saying how
he went to khabib's camp
and you know he
trained with uh makchev and khabib
the real deal man those guys are savages
savages yeah
that's it man that's it just one
memorial day show for you guys hashtag
no days off here
but uh no disrespect
shout to all the the veterans who gave
up their lives so we can continue to
live ours
yeah we love you guys man you got a
fight night this friday
you got volkov saturday saturday yep
saturday it's at uh 1 p.m pacific yeah
volkov rosenstruk
fork in the road for both gentlemen
um i do think volkov gets it done
dan ige
uh
mo mo mozar
that's a great fight
um alonzo menofield versus ascar is a
great fight you got felicia herring
first carolina kovalkiewicz yep that's a
good one
[Music]
undercards a little
dicey yeah
you know that volkov rosenstein volkov's
gonna win that decision
and uh i think your mvp is gonna come
out of either alonso versus ascar or dan
ige versus uh mofsar that's what i think
is gonna happen there cool
is that it that's it all right kids next
week uh one night 8 p.m shopping friends
with hollywood improv my home my
my home club is the hollywood improv
it's shopping friends some monsters and
guess you guys can guess who those
monsters are but we always have a
monster special guest that's one show
only 8 pm this will be our 11th or 12th
sell out if we sell this [ __ ] out so
let's keep it going la i love you guys
shout out to hollywood improv for
allowing me to do that
and then next thursday friday saturday
portland oregon i'm at the hilum in
portland one of the best clubs in the
country june 9th through the 11th um you
can find me at the helium in portland
next week or at voodoo donuts either or
pick your poison and then san francisco
cobb comedy club is june 7th and 18th
that's just a friday and saturday in san
francisco 13th 17th what'd i say i don't
know 7th or 8th my bad june 17th through
the 18th is cobb's comedy club in san
francisco i've been there in a hot
second san fran show your boy some love
and then just added to the freaking
summer tour trash panda summer tour just
so you guys know we get emails all the
time it's a whole new hour there's
nothing from the special gringo poppy
that is in this new hour it's all new
nobody has seen it uh fort wayne indiana
is july 14th through the 16th san diego
california laugh factory san diego in
the heart of downtown san diego's july
21st through the 23rd
baltimore august 4th through the 6th and
that is the all-new all-new hour trash
panda summer tour coming live with the
thick boy crew uh and again for we did
the celebration for the milly dinner
with the staff i told my staff thank you
very much for that that was amazing yes
sir you guys ordered way too many
t-bones so um i won't eat right for the
next three months that's fine it's a
celebration we went shout to scopa for
sending that all up for us but uh we had
the millie celebration we passed a milli
that thing's trending towards two
million i don't know what we're gonna do
we hit two million we'll have to decide
after this but uh keep it going i think
we're at 1.2 million downloads now we
get two million i don't know what the
hell i'm gonna do we're gonna have to
figure it out fellas but uh if you
haven't seen it
if you have seen it send to your friends
your mom your grandma your gay aunt i
don't care man let's get this thing to
two million that's the goal the goal has
always been a million i can't believe
that thing even got to a million forget
two million i don't know what we do male
star only fans something like that i
don't know but the green girl poppies on
thick boy youtube right now the goal now
is 2 million we're at 1.2
insane i love you guys thank you so much
for watching this show hope you like tj
dillashaw we have a food truck this
wednesday with cheeto vera
and uh yeah man we keep it rolling i
love you guys thanks for watching get
get your new thick boy summer gear we
have the summer glaze uh drop the two
t-shirts white black
and then also the uh
the summer yellow hoodie as well
and then we have the thick boy fight
club uh which is
uh kind of a re-invention of the abbott
kenny fight club it's thick boy fight
club hoodies tees all that's on
thickboy.com right now we have the hats
the gringo poppy uh special t-shirt it's
all there all right that's it kids i
love you thanks for watching portland
you're up next week i will see you very
soon portland i love you guys be nice to
each other happy memorial day shout out
to all the troops out there shout out to
everyone that's given up their freedom
so we can live this crazy life i love
you guys till next time i'm out
you